we're not trained or educated in any way
to think of ourselves as creators and
that's the term I like to use creator
you know because you can be creating
anything it's wet its websites its
videos its interviews its events right
but until you actually step out and you
really we're you're putting yourself on
the line right like people who are
endlessly just accumulating knowledge
and queuing up
I mean that is that is it's such a it's
such a non participatory way of living
in my view you know better to read one
consume one-tenth as much as much
information online and actually put that
to use rather than just like racking up
the you know the vanity metrics ladies
and gentlemen welcome back I'm joined by
tiago Forte of forte labs we have
already bonded over the fact that he too
is an air pods evangelist and i think
that gives you a bit of an idea about
what we're in for today we're going to
be talking digital optimization and how
we can become more efficient in our
online lives Thiago welcome to the show
thank you Chris it's really really good
to be here yeah I'm excited to go
through today so I'm gonna get straight
into it
the digital productivity pyramid was a
blog post that you wrote about a year
ago and me and a couple of friends came
across it and it was a real frame shift
for us I was super impressed with it and
I think pretty much since then I've been
hassling you in your inbox to try and
get you on so I'm very glad that we've
found some time to get the air pods in
your ears and amazing to run through
this so let's take it from the top
can you explain to people who've never
heard of yourself or Forte Labs which is
the the blogging company that you run
and or the digital productivity pyramid
can you explain what it is and your
philosophy behind it to begin with
sure sure so the pyramid really is not a
pyramid scheme I promise it is a it's a
framework it's a framework that I
developed maybe a couple years ago I
mean I for
as did a couple years ago but it's
definitely been rattling around my head
for some years and it really came about
when I when I just realized you know as
this productivity experts productivity
trainer productivity blogger I run
around every day making grand promises
of revolutionising people's work
performance and I just realized well you
have to have some theory of what
improvement even means right yeah and I
looked around and what was out there and
all the available ones you know more
tasks completed seemed completely
outdated you know minutes of focus even
kind of seems like overly simplistic I
looked at a ton of metrics I was super
involved in the quantified self-movement
for some years I've given a bunch of
talks and I just realized none of those
did the trick and so instead of focusing
on metrics on measuring some output
which I think with creative knowledge
work is basically impossible I chose to
focus on the skills
what is the ladder the pyramid of skills
that a modern knowledge worker would
need to acquire in order to execute
their work successfully and a large part
of it came about accidentally I actually
looked at my courses that I developed
you know each course that I've done came
out of the needs of the previous course
right I would create a course and then
look and then see you know the people
completing it what what are they still
meeting what are they still lacking and
then I created the next course and I've
only done three courses but those are
the first three levels of the pyramid
and now I have my eye on the fourth
level which is starting to emerge really
it's emerging it's it's appearing before
my eyes as the next thing that people
need we can get into what each of one of
those are but that's the basic story I
understand yes I was reading deep work
by Cal Newport recently I know it's
overdue and these publishers sent me
very kindly thank you Carl has sent me
digital minimalism as well which is next
on the list to read but going through
deep work listeners at home who are
knowledge workers may not quite
understand what we mean when we say that
the output is difficult to define but if
you were to think back to a typical job
50 to 100 years ago
cranking widgets I think is the the term
that Cal Newport uses which is where you
would have some
shop worker you would have a bucket of
unde important one side a machine that
was a process in the middle and a bucket
of completed parts on the other side it
was very easy for you to see when a part
was uncompleted in process and completed
it was also easy for you to track how
much was to be done and how much you had
done whereas it's a lot more kind of
nebulous and cloudy and just difficult
to define you wake up with an amount of
emails in your inbox and sometimes you
go to bed with more having done loads
all day and you have these serendipitous
were open workspaces which Karl's very
critical of and yeah I think you've hit
the nail on the head there saying that
it's difficult to define when work gets
done and your solution to that as you're
suggesting is to focus on building a
latticework of effective skills and
frameworks that you can work upon and
hopefully allowing the outputs to kind
of look after themselves on the other
side is that right it is it is yeah and
it's it's not that the outputs don't
matter or something like that it's it's
that they're sort of outside of my
purview you know I I don't I don't think
there is a way it's like all the
mechanical sort of widget jobs like you
said have now been taken by machines the
only ones that are left are inherently
ambiguous inherently undefined
inherently unstructured and by
definition you can't you know metrics
require repeatability metric one is only
meaningful with the repeatable process
so when you're doing essentially art and
I know people hate the idea that they're
artists but basically in a way we are
all artists now defining the problem is
like most of the work right so I guess
you can make a metric you know problems
define but it just gets it just gets
really weird and actually can be can be
bad when you focus on a metric to the
exclusion of the experience of the
satisfaction of the fulfillments which
when you're doing work like we're doing
that's creative you it being motivated
and satisfied fulfilled is not optional
that's not like oh it's great that you
like your factory job it's like you
literally cannot go on you cannot give
of yourself what you have to give to do
that
work if you're not fulfilled I
understand there is an inherent degree
of satisfaction that comes with crossing
things off a list we are as well as
being airport evangelists we're also big
lovers of the Pomodoro Technique and
using the very obvious crossing off of
the list or the colouring out or the
ticking off of an item there is such a
and it's so it's such a comment right on
modern knowledge work that we need to
kind of artificially create this done
big button that we hit that identifies
the fact that we've actually completed
something but it's it's the antidote to
a degree of this
I don't know when work begins and work
ends I think there was a statistic that
80% of American knowledge workers check
their emails after 11:00 at night and
before 7:00 in the morning like both of
them so you like you may be getting up
at 3:00 in the morning to check your
emails like who so I think you're
totally right with what you say so
moving on to the pyramid itself there's
some core principles and then there's
some layers some levels should I say
where we gonna start I mean we can just
start at the bottom and work our way up
let's go okay so the well first of all
let me just say what the the five layers
or levels of the pyramid are the first
base layer is what I call digital
fluency and I'll describe that in a
minute the second one on top of that is
task management and workflow basically
to-do lists the third one is habit
formation and behavior change which
you're very familiar with the fourth
level is what I call personal knowledge
management PKM which is essentially
storing your knowledge in some sort of
digital tool you know offloading that
knowledge from your brain onto onto a
software program and the fifth level
which is the most currently ambiguous
the most mysterious but also I think
eventually kind of the culmination of
all of this is a framework I'm
developing a methodology on developing
called just-in-time project management
interesting
josée is that gonna be tip of the spear
for you probably oh yeah yeah it all
comes back to the same stuff so yet so
the basic idea is that the the levels go
from more I'd say more basic at the
bottom to more advanced or more
sophisticated at the top but I wouldn't
really say they go from easy to hard
right because what's hard is just
whatever level you're currently working
on right and in some ways the base level
which is is essentially just like how to
use a computer is the hardest right if
you know someone you know I know people
my parents age you know if they never
learn to do that basically they're
they're kind of not going to be able to
take advantage of all the other levels
so so yeah I'll just talk about that um
actually I'll say one more thing about
that so each level builds on the one
before and so what that means is that
each level is sort of enabling or
setting the ground for the level above
it it's kind of like a hierarchy of
skills or a hierarchy of knowledge it's
like you have to start at the bottom but
then once you create a layer for
yourself you have then the skills and
the knowledge to start building the
second layer and then the last thing
I'll say about that is there is also
this kind of a spiral effect sometimes I
get people like ok I'm just gonna finish
one level a hundred percent completely
and then do the whole second level
perfectly but that's not quite how it
works it's kind of more like a cycle I
mean that the truth is that we're all
always working on all levels right you
never completely master any one domain
so you know I just took a course on
MailChimp learning how to use you know
an email newsletter program and that is
that at the base level that's how to use
a particular technology but I found that
I wasn't able to work at the higher
levels until I kind of put that brick in
the base of the pyramid which is how to
use them how to use MailChimp so you
can't do tasks and management workflow
of your MailChimp system until you've
got level one digital fluency with
MailChimp yes
this is always that director I'd say not
usually that direct sometimes you can
learn parts of higher order skills or
learn them in a certain way or learn
just enough to outsource them there's
there's different things but the pyramid
shape makes it sound very like you know
monument and very rigid it's really not
I mean this is human humans so
everything is quite intertwined I get
you so digital fluency we're going to
start at the bottom what's some of the
skills that people need to be developing
there and how can they develop them yeah
so really this comes from my time
working so actually in high school
in high school I had a little business
fixing Windows computers and I would go
this was really the start of my I didn't
know it at the time or for many years
but the start of what I would ultimately
do is I would go around mostly to my
parents friends and then their friends
and the neighbors and then their
neighbors fixing their you know this was
Windows XP high and the things that's
and it was really funny because I would
build by the hour and a pretty pretty
darn good rate for high school students
but then every single time after
listening very you know empathetically
to their their problem that unique
unique problems they were having I would
just always apply the exact same
solution I imagine there's a lot of
physios listening that must feel the
same thing people that do support like
strength and conditioning it I've got
this very unique pain in my knee and
this than any other and they'll just
send them away with the basics that work
well exactly yeah my solution was to
wipe their hard drive and reinstall
windows XP you just playing the game
Tiago it's fine won it was wonderful but
I don't know I learned a lot in that job
and then in my in my subsequent job in
college which was at the Apple Store so
that was a similar thing where I was a
one of those people that teach so I
would teach a morning class you know at
this time just and still millions of
people around the world were switching
to Mac's
it was kind of the golden era of
switching and I would teach them how to
use their Macs
so basically all the lessons from there
I distilled into what is it three times
four twelve kind of
specific technological skills I'd say
are tools that I think you need to know
at some point or another cool and those
are really just basic computer usage so
you know turning on your computer how to
use email actually those are other ones
so how to browse the web how to use your
email how to send and receive emails
then kind of getting more advanced
keyboard shortcuts for the programs that
you use the most digital calendars
scheduling apps for scheduling
appointments and meetings and things
like that read later apps so you read
you know you find an article online you
want to read you save it to apps like
pockets and instant paper then we
proceed to inbox zero so not just using
email but using it systematically in a
way that you're consistently closing the
loops in there then password management
so you're not having to remember
passwords or even worse use the same
password everywhere then there's three
more speed reading time tracking and
text expanders I'm looking through that
list in my own mind and realizing that
even at the bottom level of a pyramid
that I hold in very high regard there's
still massive holes in my game so I
think for the vast majority of people
they will consider basic computer usage
or most of the listeners consider basic
computer usage web browsing email usage
should be pretty simple keyboard
shortcuts for things like YouTube Kay
pauses and L&J jump forward and back 10
seconds and command + V and command + C
and stuff like that I'm gonna guess is
there have you are you familiar with
Alfred Alfred app oh yeah I'm a big
Alfred man oh you are among friends here
Tiago really this is a safe space for
you to talk about this your snippets and
your workflow and everything the
listeners at home head to Alfred app
comm you you need it in your life if
you're on Mac and if you're on Windows
unlucky because they literally do not do
not even make it for Windows yeah I know
so digital calendars what do you use
I know that we did this over Google
Calendar are you Google Calendar man
yeah yeah it's really just Google
Calendar but I'm still amazed how many
people don't have digital calendars I
regularly encounter even professionals
with years of experience who are still
using paper my business was amazing my
business partner has a Filofax like a1
like week per 2 pages Filofax thing that
he likes to write down and you just
likes to have it I'm like it's he's a
curmudgeon when it comes to that I will
convert him eventually but we don't know
I'm moving on to scheduling apps oh by
the way Google Calendar like you it's
I've fully transitioned now from iCal to
Google Calendar and the way that it
links in with when you get a flight like
you get an email about a fly and then
you fly infos already in Google Calendar
with you check-in and it links to the
email like it's it's so good is is
really good
scheduling apps what we're talking about
there so I use one called what is it
called there's different ones like
calendly I mean there's at least a dozen
of them every I mean it's a bit of an
issue actually because there's no
standard like there is the Google
Calendar so every time I schedule with
someone I have to sort of navigate a new
interface I wish someone would just
quite like merge them all or you know
acquire them some of the common can just
take all 12 companies yeah please if
you're listening you got a couple
billion lists you know lying around just
do it it was a solid and take care of
that okay but they it's a very standard
function it's nothing fancy there's not
that many ways to do it you know you you
designate spots on your calendar however
long you want to make available and then
instead of you know that back and forth
of Oh what time you know oh no I can't
do that time at this time blah blah blah
you just send them a link and they sort
of schedule themselves into your
calendar I understand read later apps we
are big fans of pocket here
I love the feature that pocket has where
it will on mobile turn text-to-speech
have you seen this yes so yes basically
turns any article into an audiobook and
it's pretty for text-to-speech that's
done on mobile like it is pretty legible
big fan of that
Toby as an extension for Chrome have you
ever tried that oh no I haven't heard of
that
so Toby for Mac this by the way
listeners these show notes I can already
tell that the show notes for this
episode are going to be absolutely humor
but Toby for Mac is similar every time
you open a new tab it opens up a list of
basically very well curated read later
bookmarks you can imagine it as a very
visual favorites list or to be read list
but it's every time you open a new tab
Toby comes up so it just makes you think
it pops it in your head like oh [ __ ] I
need to read that I need to read that I
need to do this so it's a it's quite a
useful way to do it but it does not sync
with your mobile device which is where
pocket comes in and wins I think in BA
inbox zero will be a concept that a lot
of people especially my business
partners wife Killeen who has like
10,000 unread emails will be alien with
can you explain why it's important yeah
so emails interesting I'm actually I'm
doing a walk through tomorrow on the
super human app what's up have you seen
super super human it's this this
productivity app that sort of made waves
in the past couple years for
revolutionising the email experience and
it's most known for its most known for
its eye-popping $30 a month price and
for and for its waiting list which has
like 200,000 people and they only lets
you know small numbers of people use it
at a time so it has it's sort of like
greatly in demand to even be able to use
it but but anyway I think people's email
usage goes through phases you know when
you first I see my younger brother you
know he's just just starting his career
it's like email is this like it's like
postal mail it says vaguely annoying
thing he pays minimal attention to take
some weeks to even open it it's like
very kind of low price
right and then most people I think when
you when you get your first sort of
professional job you kind of have a
shock of cold water in the face when you
realize whoa people expect me to
actually keep up with these things yeah
this high and it's reals in the face of
constant emails you need to reply or
respond yeah it really is
and and I think we all sort of do a mix
of whatever we can it's like you know
survival sinking ship style or maybe if
we're lucky we have someone a model
around us who teaches us something about
how to use email or maybe ideally
ideally we read an article or take the
course or do something like that and
there's just many many levels just
within that one little thing and inbox
zero to me is it's not just this you
know kind of bragging right that you
have an empty inbox although that's nice
it's the it's just the fact that you're
not using your email as its do list
right which is what most people do each
email in their inbox is an open loop
it's a task that they have to take care
of and I wrote this article one of my
most popular all-time articles it's
called one touch to inbox zero is that
word Isis all four different pathways is
there's four things you can do yes that
has been linked by Jordan who's a friend
of the show in our private member's
group he put that someone had complained
about the fact that he couldn't manage
his inbox and he said man there's only
four things that you ever need to do so
what are the four things cuz I can't
remember let's see if I can remember oh
here we go the pressures on I mean it's
it's so engrained at this point let's
see I mean it's either archived
immediately and that's the really the
most common case you know the the
amazing thing of emails we use it for so
many things but one of those things is
just notifications yeah right just
something happened that package was
delivered a subscription renewed
something happened out there and you
don't need really any any more than a
split second of attention on it or if
any so it's just archive just see it
delete it yeah or rather archive so it's
so which is different in Gmail so you
can refer to it later yeah the second is
make a task out of it and this is the
like Veeck rut like the key feature of
any task manager I need to do list out
that
ask people to look for is the ability to
create a new task with a link that goes
back to the original email like that one
little thing is unbelievably
revolutionary what do you use what about
I use things I've always used things
thing yeah it's called things never
heard of it
he really we're open all we're opening a
portal here to y'all go come on tell me
about it oh my gosh things is just
phenomenal
right now it's made it's made by a
German company called cultured code
which i think is key to its success it
doesn't you know they're they're
sometimes criticized for their lack of
feature development they release a new
version every few years but but I think
that's amazing
like I hate when my core productivity
apps are constantly releasing new
features when when I've come to depend
on whatever the workflow is so I don't
know the culture code just has an
absolutely incredible design sense that
every little like I discovered things
after years little touches little
decisions they made that you know they
spent hours and hours and hours talking
about and thinking about it's really my
favorite productivity app it's called
things wow that is that is big okay so
things will be linked in the show notes
below I'm I'm excited to go and get
stuck into all of these once we get on
so we've got created I create a task
from the email which has come in
I'm gonna guess especially for me a lot
of the time that's if it's not import
not urgent but important in the
eisenhower matrix that's where I get a
fair bit of this stuff with land and if
it's not just yeah your your Amazon
order has been confirmed
that's probably well like a fair bit of
Evan box stuff will come to I guess
especially directly addressed stuff it's
not just like part of a big five person
CC loop that you're not commenting in
yes yes exactly yeah there's actually I
pulled up the article here there's
actually so there's six apps that you
can send send an email to but there's
actually six actions okay to two of
those actions are archive and reply
right so you just delete it or you
actually keep the open loop going by
replying in some way at the end of
or apps to interject that Iago people
may be thinking I'm doing Pomodoro's I
don't want to interrupt my workflow the
way that I would format that is I would
have a designated Pomodoro every four or
something like that that you would
actually focus on right the start of
this Pomodoro is going to be email work
and then I'll get back to it also David
Allen's getting things done his
two-minute rule I'm a pretty big fan of
that it's like look if you can just do
it if it pops up there's a notification
you've left on somewhere cuz do not
disturb not on which is bad idea but you
just reply to it like crack it out if
it's there and it's in front of you in
it's a three-second job like just yes
tomorrow whatever like get it done
exactly cool yeah yeah totally agree but
then the four apps are basically I said
task manager I already read later app
there's a second one you just something
you want to read but you're definitely
as you just refer to don't want to now
interrupt your email to go read
something it's even worse yeah
the third is to add it to a reference
app on note-taking apps such as Evernote
or bear or OneNote or one of these
that's like if you there's a snippet of
text you need to save an attachment you
know is going to be important and then
the fourth is to add something your
calendar which is more and more
automated these days it's usually just a
little kind of email that you hit yes or
accept and then it gets added so those
are the those are the six the only six
things you can do with any given email
isn't it amazing that you can distill
email down
that's this crazy big monster to just
six things I could do one of these six
things and you haven't you have zero
unread emails in your mug yet yeah I
know when one of these days I'll record
this but no one believes this but I do a
weekly review every every week on Monday
and it takes me just about an hour maybe
a most an hour and a half I I'm more or
less ignoring my email the whole whole
week like I'll pop in just if I know
something's coming or just to see if
there's something important but I just
let it accumulate let it accumulate
because actually on Monday I want there
to be as many emails as possible because
then I can batch process all of them in
one gigantic session which is still only
an hour but you know once you get going
and you really
get in the mindset of these six things I
mean it's seconds you're spending
seconds per email which completely
changes the equation I love it
password management this is one that I
am very interested to hear about what
you use I'm a huge fan of one password
okay it's just the number one plus the
word password and it's just I mean it's
just a game-changer like I used to use
the same email the same password
I mean I'm amazed I didn't I never got
hacked or had money stolen or anything
and then I you know at some point I
developed this more sophisticated system
where I was like the name of the website
plus like the date like some other
variable and then and then my standard
password and it started taking up so
much cognitive bandwidth that I just
thought I can't do it anymore especially
now that I see in my password manager I
have over 300 logins you know you've I
don't think people realize how many
different accounts they have online but
basically one password just when you
need a password you just hit generate
password it generates this long
alphanumeric and symbol string which is
impossible to crack and then it inserts
your your username and your password
saves it for you and then if you ever
come back to that website again it
recognizes the website and you just hit
the little chrome plug-in and it inserts
it right there it's just incredible yeah
totally right I am I had LinkedIn
recently how to date a loss and my I
must have used the same LinkedIn
password as I did for my delivery
account and someone in London ordered
themselves like 40 pounds worth of
Nando's to their to their address off
the back of the works that yeah I'm
being am being serious and then I had to
go through this massive rigmarole with
delivery room that I didn't order this
thing it happened it was on my business
partners business card as well so he was
like me what's this forty pounds but why
were you in London Audrey Nando's and I
was I oh god that wasn't me went back
through and sure enough it was a
LinkedIn data breach
so yes use user password management or
all someone's gonna sting you for 40
quids worth of takeaway food
so next speed reading yeah speed reading
is when I kind of had there tentatively
I've never done anything with speed
reading I think I read in fact I know
I've tested it I read quickly pretty
naturally I think that's from reading so
much as a kid I was such a such a
voracious reader as a kid so it's not
it's not become a bottleneck for me in
any way yeah but just based on what I've
seen from others I think if you don't
have that naturally that it can be a
game-changer so I kind of have it there
as if that's something that you feel is
starting to limit you is there a
technique to that or is it just trying
to read more quickly I don't know the
names there's a few I've seen that
seemed to produce miraculous results but
I've just never gotten into it called
Tim Ferriss has a good this is only four
books off a Kindle but Tim Ferriss has a
good breakdown of how you can speed read
books more easily by bringing your eyes
in from the margins and by actually
using a ruler below each line to track
down which is kind of which is which is
interesting but Tim Ferriss is super
adamant and if Tim says them
I'm gonna probably presume that he's
right time tracking is up next
yeah time tracking is amazing and it's
not like it's funny people have really
weird sort of associations with time
tracking I think they think of the punch
card they have you know trauma from
their nine-to-five job where they had to
you know be there exactly from this time
to that time or maybe they were paid by
the hour so they sort of it feels like a
ball and chain but I think when you
become more autonomous and whether
that's being a freelancer an
entrepreneur or just as valid just being
higher up in your organization where you
kind of have you know freedom to work
how you want to work time tracking
becomes this whole it becomes basically
a tool of self-awareness
you know people people have such bad
intuition about time that in time is is
is the currency of life I mean obviously
it's the it's just the basic building
block of all experience until you have a
sense you know like I think if I used to
quote jobs like I would have a project
oh yeah build this website yeah I can
build a website in two hours
you know and then you and then you do
the time tracking and actually track
that project and then you look at the
end and you see like I literally had
projects when I was first getting
started what you know when I had had
could barely pay the rent but I would
make much less than minimum wage by the
time all the time was factored in yeah
like way less yeah and then I would look
at other projects that were I had some
source of leverage or maybe I reused
past knowledge or something this is
actually what got me started with
knowledge management as I realized if I
can complete a project in half the time
because of this existing knowledge that
I've captured then my per hour rate
doubles yeah and I would have like a
like a 50 literally a 50 times
differential between per hour between my
lowest paid project and my highest now
guess which one I should take in the
future yeah yeah right so it's pretty
amazing so how are you tracking your
time what are you using so I don't
anymore actually I kind of think of it
as a face yeah it's it's a phase and it
one may come again if I need to build up
the self-awareness again but for about
three years I used hours tracker which
is a little app a paid app I think
there's a free version too for iOS I'm
not sure it might have an Android
version by now too but it's just very
simple you know what I really don't
recommend is automatic time tracking
things like out like rescue time or
what's the other one there's another one
that starts with the T because that you
can't if you make something automatic so
therefore you don't pay attention to it
you can't build self-awareness right and
plus that data is not useful it's like
oh I spent you know seven hours today on
my web browser well everything happens
in the browser it's pointless so what
our structure forces you to do is manual
it's really like a punch clock you say
I'm gonna do this now and then you use
select that project or that activity and
then when you're done you say I'm
finished and you clock out and it's
amazing what what a forcing function it
creates right because once you've
clocked in and then you go to reach for
social media or email or something else
you go oh no I have to protect my data
integrity you stay on track just just
because that's what you clocked in to
you know yeah I get you so to say
it's work out what you've had on screen
versus what you should be doing or is
that just the back of your mind your own
discipline telling you that you need to
stop being and being naughty and
sneaking off from the back of the class
with regards to you saying not to use
social media yeah it's completely
unconnected to your computer so nothing
happens automatically it's just the way
that I recommend people do it is based
on projects and areas so if you can't so
projects is better if you can sort of
assign this block of time to a specific
project do it
and that requires changing the items
that you track occasionally or
frequently which is a little bit of
friction but what that allows you to do
is that sort of post hoc analysis that I
mentioned where you can actually figure
out what what things take and yeah with
the important part of this is doing the
analysis you need to export this data to
an Excel spreadsheet later you have to
look at it break it down by you know
monk-like season by client by project by
all these things you can do by day of
the week I I came up with all these
interesting insights like you'll you'll
love this one I I found out that my
average rate of task completion over a
period of like three years was eight
point one per day fantastic see this is
the sort of thing that I like to think
about before I go about at night that's
a good evening with a spreadsheet and
some nice data in front of me fantastic
and that's hours h o urs yep hours
tracker one word fantastic text expander
is we're talking about Alfred yes yeah I
originally used a different one called 8
X but then they stopped supporting it so
now I use really that's that's the main
feature of Alfred that I use besides the
search is this they're called snippets
and I have them for my all the usual
stuff my address my phone number might
you know you you know when I'm sitting
next to each other and I watch them type
out their email address now I'm just
like whoa so I'm the lot of the
listeners at home we'll know what we are
talking about but on iOS there is an
equivalent if you go to
general Settings General keyboard text
replacement there is exactly the same
thing so if you have a commonly written
out sentence or even a paragraph I have
mine um which is actually an artifact of
blackberry days that they had set in
there they had mine um and my pin and
that would just expand out into your
number or your PIN and you can have all
sorts of stuff interesting what do you
use for how are you using keyboard
shortcuts what do you want for your
address for instance I just do hash tag
a and it inputs my address
I do hash tag P for my phone number
let's see what else I have all my
websites you know yeah so I have adult
the dollar sign is the prefix for
anything business-related so you know
dollar sign w eb is my website dollar
sign t is twitter dollar sign f is
facebook it's like when people's likes n
with someone's like send me your links
it's just like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam yeah
it's Bruce just like five in a row I
love it and then actually another really
cool use is is verbs action verbs so
when I create a to-do and think so this
is something I'm gonna you know
something I have to do in the future
yep it's tempting to sort of come up
with words on the spot right so like
let's say you need to email someone you
might word that many different ways like
email let's say it's Rob email Rob
reached out to Rob follow up with Rob
send Rob yeah get in touch with there's
like like 15 different ways you might
say email yeah the issue with that is
it's really hard to batch process write
those tattles 15 tasks might be in 15
different projects so it would take half
an hour just to go find them so what I
have is if I do /e and then space it
expands into email colon and then i
around i just what i have to email and i
do that everywhere so what that means
and this is really really cool but i can
do one single search in my task manager
and it will show me across dozens of
different projects and different areas
every single task related to email and
then i can just do a massive batch
process and send
every single email that I have to send
that's awesome that is that's really
really cool
my shortcuts that I've gone to instead
of using the hashtag I'm doing a DD one
for my home address a DD two for my
office address etc etc by adding the
number in the same way as you've put the
dollar sign it's unlikely that you're
going to type that Yousef one of the
co-hosts of the show has if he writes
kind space r-e it expands out into kind
regards used to smith appropriateness
calm but because he forgets that it's
there a lot of the time he gets kind
regards to guards because he's continued
through it it's expanded out in all this
stuff and then he's written it on the
other side so you need to be careful
with your shortcuts and whilst we're on
this Thiago you should get the Twitter
plugin for Alfred which allows you to
tweet from your alfred deck have you
seen this
no ah so what's your twitter again at
forte labs forte labs to show him how
awesome Alfred
Twitter is and that's just sent from my
Knights that's sent from from my desktop
so you need you need that as well so
we're moving on to the second level now
is that correct task management and
workflow yes yes we've kind of touched
on this already but basically you know
once you have all or some of the
computer usage you know you're
comfortable with a core set of
productivity apps I'd say you can level
that up to really what is GTD like this
was that the the layer that was really
addressed by GTD which said you know the
the way that you manage tasks is not or
it doesn't have to be haphazard random
just reactive to whatever is coming
across your plate it can be systematic
and and I'm sure you're familiar with
GTD many of your listeners will be
that's really how I got my start in the
business is I had a GTD course that I
that I created and there's there's just
the five stages you know you capture
your open loops you clarify them
organize them you'll reflect on your
project list and then you engage with
whatever the most appropriate
this this is a just a massive level
upper I mean I think something like a
little over 20,000 people have taken
that course and iced it was created
almost six years ago and hasn't been
changed since then and I still get
emails every week of people at every age
every stage of life just discovering GTD
for the first time which is amazing it's
been around for almost 20 years and
realizing that there's a just a much
more sensible logical way of managing
their to-do list still relevant yeah it
really is
so really it's can you just lay out so
capture clarify organize reflect engage
can you clarify how you would
instantiate those things or a little bit
of an expansion on each of them and them
all got on the level three sure sure so
each one is is really just a principle
that can be instantiated many different
ways if we're using let's say a task
manager which is really just a digital
to-do list program it's quite simple so
capture is really just get it from out
there or in your mind somewhere into a
centralized place and that can be done
very quickly it should be done actually
quickly frictional frictionlessly you
asked before how things does this it's a
it's control space and this little tiny
window in the center of your screen pops
up and then you just type the task and
hit hit enter and it just disappears so
you don't even have to so much as switch
what program you're looking at so yeah
that's capture yeah and clarify so
because capture has to be so
frictionless right you might be in in
the middle of writing something you
might be in the middle of a meeting you
might be in the middle of a podcast
interview because capture has to be so
frictionless you want to separate the
actual thinking about what that thing
actually is into the second step which
is clarify so what you're gonna do as
you start capturing things you know
every day or two or three you're gonna
come to a Nimba arrive at an inbox full
of these things you've written down and
sometimes you're like what was I even
thinking what does that even refer to
like you have to really do some
clarifying right and clarifying can
include making it more specific
it can include adding details like who
you're supposed to call or
or what the agenda is it can include
what project it belongs to what the goal
of that task is all sorts of things got
you in that step - yeah
step three is organized so you know at
this point you still just have this this
formless sea of different tasks that
you've you've created organize is really
just to put those into projects right
projects and areas which are his two
distinctions so what you know this what
is this group of tasks over here trying
to accomplish that's a project this
group over here is a different project
this over here is an area so just kind
of grouping them and because once you
have those groups you can actually see
at a glance what is the set of
commitments the set of projects that you
currently have going which you can't do
if you just have you know 300 random
tasks and a giant list yeah yeah you are
very right to go back to just the
capture thing a quote that I've been
trying to remember that Johnny told me
about is I think it's David Allen the
mind is built for having thoughts not
holding thoughts is that David um yeah
yes and that that's so central I think
to what we have here the Zeigarnik
effect which is the open-loop
closed-loop that everyone suffers with
there's a reason the inbox zero is a
good idea it's a reason that the
two-minute rule is a good idea that
getting things out of your head and into
some sort of capture process that is
then clarified because the capture was
probably pretty quick and rough-hewn
then we've organized it we've put it
into something which is a little bit
more well formatted and underneath
headings of topics or dates or whatever
it might be and then we're gonna reflect
next yes yes so up till now you've sort
of been building and accumulating and
and defining your your to-do list but
then you know all of that goes out of
date tasks are perishable it's like
fruit what was relevant yesterday
suddenly in the light of new information
is not relevant or especially once days
weeks have passed you have to actually
refresh this list of projects and tasks
and David Allen recommends doing this in
a weekly review or a monthly review it's
taking some time and the reason uses
reflect is this is actually not a
mechanical analytical process it's you
have to step back and think okay why am
i doing all this what is it is all this
still relevant you know you don't want
to keep the heads down chugging along
for too long you want to actually think
about the big picture so that's the
reflex stage and then engage is really
just you know you sort of been preparing
all this so that when you arrive at work
in the morning right so it's that you
have that fresh mind you have a fresh
cup of coffee you're ready to go instead
of oh let me start way at the beginning
thinking of my open loops checking my
email clarifying we're gonna I think you
actually are ready to just look at your
task manager pick a subset of in my case
8.1 tasks for the day and then just
actually produce value and get things
done like the name and says instead of
plenty you know doing your work instead
of be planning your work because you've
pre-planned and pre organize all these
things I get you so with the fact that
you're capturing quite quickly and then
reflecting on a weekly basis where do
you draw the line between something
comes into your sphere of attention or
sphere of awareness someone text you
there's something that needs to be done
someone asks you a question you realize
there's something that you need to get
from the store later on or whatever it
might be when or where do you draw the
line between doing the the action now or
scheduling it for later I mean for
things so David Allen uses a two minute
rule if you just can do it immediately
do it right he kind of chose two minutes
as the threshold under which it's not
worth all this time of doing all these
things the thing is that that people and
we even talked about this when I was on
his podcast people seriously
underestimate how much or overestimate
how much two minutes is right I mean two
minutes is like nothing it's like it
goes by in a second right so you you
sort of have to in a weird way there's
something else that happens too which is
usually when you have one open loop one
thing you're trying to remember to do
you're like oh that's fine one thing I
can remember two things three things
four things and then you get around like
five or seven and it's only then
that you realize oh my gosh it's falling
out there balls are frozen under the
weight of my task fear yeah yes yeah so
so in a way you have to sort of like
underestimate yourself you could keep 5
to 7 tasks in your head but you have to
like it and it's really you have to
train yourself when one open loop
arrives or two to think okay I could
remember these but let me just capture
them right it's it's sort of it's it's a
habit it's self discipline because over
time you know you really do have like
thousands of tasks every year inbox zero
for your brain basically yeah nice yeah
so we're moving on to level 3 we
finished level 2 there right there's
nothing else that we need to touch on
there ah yeah pretty much
so habit formation and behavior change
James Claire's been on recently so
everyone will be primed and prepped
ready for this one yes so this actually
emerged um I had at my course call to
get stuff done like a boss which was on
that one on GTD but then you know I
finished the course saying you know now
you're now you know it now you have it
the only thing you must do from now on
is your weekly review okay put it on
your calendar schedule it and just do it
I was like oh yeah this this will be Z
and then of course as I follow up with
people as I hear back that's the thing
that they don't do right it's the
linchpin that the Keystone habits right
the one habit upon which all others rely
and it's hard to do you know if you're
not used to sitting inside an hour or
two a week to actually reflect on
everything you're committed to it feels
like this just tremendous burden and I
guess as well with the with the
increased velocity of capture of to-do
lists well if you don't have the reflect
what you've actually done is just pile
weight on top of yourself and you then
eventually do a undisciplined manner
look at this and you just get like get
everything in the face get hit in the
face by these old artifacts of a time
gone by when you were noting them all
down and it probably even would make
some people shy away from being so
efficient with the capture
because yes they're giving themselves
this future curse that they're gonna
have to come up against it's true
it's really true yeah it's confronting
it's very confronting you're right um so
so what be so I created a my next course
was called design your habits and it was
really at the time and actually up until
just this past December I was living in
Silicon Valley so I was just immersed in
the the power of habit stuff we've got a
habit meetups quantified self you know B
I was really into BJ Fogg and all his
stuff I went to the habits summit which
is near Isles the the author have hooked
his kind of behavior change habit design
stuff all those inventions like other
wild there's so much fun it's so much
fun because they're just uber nerds in
this particular domain just completely
amping each other up to be even more
nerdy I love it I love it I looked like
a fly on the wall that it's like
comic-con for productivity yeah I get it
everyone's tracking everything there's
people walking around with those laptop
holsters that kind of attach around your
shoulder yeah yeah yeah so the so this
course there really teaches a sort of a
systematic process for forming any
habits and in the pyramid that would be
I chose specific habits because
essentially so weekly review is kind of
a keystone habit of task management of
GTD but there's other ones as well right
for capture there's something called the
collection habit which is that thing I
mentioned of just just occurring to you
in the moment right it's not a habit
that you do like at 9:00 a.m. every
morning but it's like the trigger is oh
I'm trying to remember more than one
thing at once and then the habit is to
actually write that down for the clarify
stage then the then that the habit is
next physical action so it's basically
just to always when you do write down
that task to write it specifically
instead of like Oh figure out new
computer know it's like okay like
stall operating system and then another
you know like very precise by next
physical action there's there's two
things that coming into my mind here one
of them I think is a Pomodoro Technique
which is the advice that they have for
writing down to-do lists tasks is a
description of the state that your life
will be in upon completion of that task
what it sounds like your point here is
closer to what James clear touch is on
which is what is the first step which I
need to take which puts me on this path
of this particular process what why do
we lie in in between those two yeah I
think I think you're right they are very
different things and how you describe
like describing end States I think
that's more for goals or outcomes for me
that's the the long relatively long
distance thing so next physical action
is really a great insight from David
Allen it's just the it's the insight
that often we define our tasks as
essentially mental operations
you know like ponder reflects you know
ruminate about yes spend thirty two
minutes ruminating about topic X and and
it's tempting to do that especially with
with modern knowledge work which is so
cognitively demanding but it's it's an
issue too because mental operation is
they tend to just sort of like they're
not concrete not tangible they don't
really have a clear beginning an end
it's not clear when you've done them
right so it's much better according to
this methodology to just say what is the
thing you'll have to do in order to do
that thinking right like he gives the
example decide like decide seems very
clear-cut oh you just like go into your
brain and you make a decision but almost
always if you can't make that decision
instantly there's something you have to
do you have to talk to someone you have
to make a list of pros and cons you have
to do some brainstorming something right
and it's better to write down that task
because it's something you can achieve
you can accomplish rather than just some
ethereal you know idea I understand so
what is the literal next action
you need to take that progress is you
along whatever path has been laid down
through the collection yes course so
organized that's project list yeah so
the project list probably doesn't sound
like a habit but it's essentially the
habit of maintaining it this is
something I teach in in the in battery
two of these courses but your project
list is an absolutely fundamental piece
of your productivity it's really it's
really something that's unavoidable you
know people tend to think of their of
their work in terms of tasks which is to
low level you know they're to especially
if you follow this method they're too
specific for you to really see the big
picture
whereas goals are to our two big picture
right it doesn't help you to know in
three years you want to have your your
blood in the south of Italy okay well I
just need to know what I'm supposed to
do now and project projects are really
the medium resolution right it's like
the medium elevation where they're
tangible and concrete enough that you
could see the path more or less to get
there but also big enough that they
could actually have a huge impact you
know if you successfully complete a
major project that is a huge win and
David Ellen has this quote that he you
know he has the same kind of
preoccupation he's like the but the
biggest thing that I'm mystified by is
the number of high-performing people
that just do not have a project list
like they just don't maintain it so
that's the habit you alright so how do
you actually instantiate that is it just
once you have your rough hewn bunch of
things that you've put down your lumping
them into a clearly defined set of
categories yeah yeah it's just it's it's
assigning your next actions your tasks
to their appropriate projects but also
it's it's a way of thinking too right
it's it's just thinking in terms of
projects instead of like it learned
Spanish that's a classic one I see oh
yeah that's a goldmine learn spent okay
but that's not a project you know it has
no end you don't reach a day where you
know you just like have learned Spanish
it's and it's an infinite game it's a
never-ending thing
and so much better than that is to pick
a at first small achievable thing like
complete rosetta stone or complete the
babble modules for Spanish beginner just
beginner once alright then you can
achieve that project and then you like
think about what you learned or relate a
new project really on the way to any
goal especially any you know major goal
there should be a a step a long series
of stepping stones and those stepping
stones are whole projects you know I do
this case study in in my other course
building a second brain of you know
redesigning my website where if you
really break down redesigning website
it's like a dozen different projects
right because you have to like create
things you have to create I know I had
to create my brochure because I wanted
to put it on there I had to get
headshots oh my gosh getting headshots
on all project by itself and then only
when I'd completed most of those dozen
projects did it even make sense to touch
the web design itself I understand I'm
gonna guess that as we move down we're
going to touch on this but have you got
a way whereby people take goals or
overall the overall ephemeral stuff and
got top-down and turn them from goals
and objectives into projects and into
actions because we're kind of going
bottom-up here right like something
appears in your sphere of awareness it
then gets instantiated in and lumped
into one of the projects if you don't
have your projects there you can't do
this yeah so it this is very funny I get
this question a lot because essentially
no I don't really do that and the reason
I think so a couple reasons first is
that that's what most others do and
there's definitely huge value in it but
um every productivity book I've read
goal-setting methodology course I've
done is that you know is what is your
what is your 10-year vision your
long-term thing you life you want to
have what are your goals all these
things and then they sort of cascade
those goals down into specific outcomes
and then projects and then tasks and
that has value it's super it's super
good to do I do it from time to time but
the the my general philosophy that
you'll see in this whole pyramid
actually is something that I haven't
seen which is sort of like
Mergent productivity right in an
environment where you don't know what
the final goal is right were you're
doing ambiguous creative work where
you're as we said before discovering
what the goals are as you make progress
on them you have to let things emerge
right you have to you have to sort of do
a fundamental series of activities that
produce value and then as you see the
value you're producing you sort of take
a step back and you go oh there seems to
be a lot of value being produced in this
part of my life
let me now retro actively think of a
goal that makes use of that value so the
listeners who call it tuned into the
James clear episode from a few weeks ago
will know that James talked a lot about
this he talked about our genes do not
predetermine but they do predispose and
he suggests the fact that someone who
has both a talent or capacity in a
particular area and a passion is a very
dangerous individual for whatever that
domain of competence is and obviously
what you're allowing to happen there is
I'm just gonna start doing stuff I'll
just do some stuff and see where I
appear to be effective and the places
that you are most effective in probably
quite likely will be where your
competence is highest and also your
motivation or feeling of fun the metric
that James uses is what do you do that
to you feels like fun but to everyone
else feels like work yeah and it
wherever that lies is you know okay
we'll start to exploit that a little bit
I'll have a look it I'll have a look at
what happens over on that side maybe I'm
getting a little bit bored of that and
but you know you've started to gear
yourself towards that in a very bizarre
way it's a very philosophical solution
to what is an incredibly modern problem
isn't it it can get pretty philosophical
it is fundamentally a different protein
ah'd only to productivity but kind of to
life you know it's like it's like you're
let the point of your life is not to
conform to a set of a priori objectives
that you
imagined at some very early immature
stage the point of life is to experience
life right and to experience it in a not
always controlled way right like to to
fully I was just writing about this in a
blog post like you know it is the lack
of control of life that allows life to
be exciting and invigorating and just
just from time to time absolutely
terrifying but I mean life is worth
living because it's unpredictable and I
think I'm sort of like putting that into
my productivity philosophy by saying
allow your goals to be discovered or
even in a within a way to discover you
allow your goals to set you instead of
you setting your goals I love that
that's really that's really nice way to
put it and I doubt that many people
would have presumed that a digital
productivity pyramid would have
encapsulated something that was quite so
fluffy and philosophical and conceptual
but here we are so we're moving on to
reflect the weekly review which is the
linchpin as you said of this particular
this particular habit set yes yes so
it's it's really a habit this is the
only one of these habits actually that
it's sort of fixed in time you know you
can say I think David Allen recommends
Wednesday afternoon everyone has their
theory of oh the one time you must do it
when do you know I don't so I actually
don't have oh God Iago you mumbling you
on a minute basis here I know everything
it's clear that I don't follow my own
advice but um so my so okay I always do
it around the same time actually that's
not even true the way that I do my
weekly review is based on the level of
perspective that I need and this is this
is actually the thing looking at this
whole pyramid every time there's like a
fixed recommendation you have to do it
this way really that's a spectrum right
it can be adjusted up and down depending
on your needs and I think that's a
higher level of sophistication
you know you at first you you slavishly
follow the two-minute rule and that's
useful you want to discipline yourself
according to that standard but then you
realize oh actually you know an example
is when you come back from vacation and
you have you know 2,000 emails or
something to read if you follow the
2-minute rules you're gonna be doing
nothing but answering emails for three
and a half days yeah right so in that
case you have to adjust that threshold
down to say 30 seconds and only actually
respond to something that is like really
really fast yeah and the same thing is
true of your weekly review so you know
sometimes I'm working it's clear it's
clear to me what I need to be working on
for a few weeks at a time right if I'm
working on say a manuscript of my book
right I don't need in fact it's actually
bad it throws me off course for me to
grind that to a halt you know all that
mental momentum of like the manuscript
to stop I don't know it's it's Wednesday
at 3:30 p.m. I have to do my weekly
review yeah you want to actually just
just maximize that forward momentum but
when I know I need to do my weekly
review is when I wake up in the morning
and I just had this feeling I'm not sure
what I should be doing today to me
that's the trigger of oh it's time to
take a step back we redo reconnaissance
and all my projects redo my calendar
it's like get everything back into shape
so that I can have that clarity again I
get it
all so I totally understand what you
mean about the fact that upon
instantiating a lot of the strategies
that we're going through today these
rigid rules are a good way to do them
it's the same reason that when anyone
who's ever taken a martial arts class
they will learn how to jab and the
process for a jab or Brazilian jiu-jitsu
the you know taking whatever the
fundamentals are are quite rigidly
defined because it is a useful framework
for a beginner to layer they're
non-existent understanding over but this
conversation between myself and you is
like a blue belt talking to like a
seventh degree like black belt and
you're now in this place where you are
able to feel with a lot more fidelity
and play around with the parameters of
what the emergence of these strategies
actually means and it's that the weekly
review is there every single week at the
same time to create this framework and
it makes you accountable and it gives
you this this
repetition so that you learn to
instantiate it but you are right like
you would the reason it's there at
weekly is presumably a week is around
about the iteration like length that's
that's about right for you to need to do
it but completely correct sometimes it
might be a month sometimes it might be
twice a week so yeah I think you're
you're allowed to when you when you're
tiago forte you're allowed to to play
around with the rules and break them
sometimes yeah exactly yeah it's it's
it's simply an any domain I think you're
right no in writing you can only you can
break the rules and produce incredible
innovative pieces of writing but only
after you've mastered them right if
you're a beginner trying to just break
rules it's just gonna be you know
nonsensical you know whatever yeah
because it's not emergent from an
understanding of the rules themselves
right exactly so engage context slash
priorities I don't know what this means
yeah so Alan has this idea of context
which is the the the way you should
decide what to do at any given time is
based on the context in which you find
yourself
right it's not based on strict priority
it's not based on it's just based on so
for example you know if you are on the
train and you only have your mobile
device let's say you should only do
tasks that are amenable that makes sense
to do on your mobile device
in that situation right you shouldn't
sit down and try to like do some big
heavy lift if you know that you're gonna
be getting off in ten minutes if you are
you know walking through the city and
you have your phone you should make
phone calls you shouldn't try to like I
mean you could walk and like be typing
on your phone or something yeah but that
doesn't make sense why while walking
through a city you should make phone
calls yeah right so and that's different
from priority it's like it's basically
saying that the prep the top priority in
any given moment depends on in his case
he said the the energy you have how much
energy is is available to you the tools
you have how much time you have and then
finally last is the actual urgency that
put the priority of it yeah I guess
there's probably quite a lot of Devil's
in the details with regards to that this
final one this engaged
contexts and priorities I imagine like
creating a formalized framework for this
and instantiating it probably a bit more
a bit more difficult to define
it's probably an experience game a
little bit so once again you can take
his four contexts as a starting point I
don't find them all that useful anymore
I have some some writing I've done about
this where you know in the past your
tool largely determine your context
whether you had your computer your phone
you're at the office not at the office
but now with the phone or the smartphone
you know GTD was formulated before
smartphones you could in theory do
anything anywhere at any time yeah so so
I have a post on this called
productivity for precious snowflakes hmm
that's a column which is what's such a
great title it's one of my all-time most
popular and most favorite posts still
comes around on Twitter once in a while
but basically it's it's that I'm
proposing a theory that the new sort of
constraint on what you can do is your
mood that how you what you feel like
doing basically it's the best basis on
which to choose what to do which
requires you know a 5,000 word posts to
fully explain but I'll let your readers
find that if they're interested they'll
track it down so we're moving on the
level for will high up on the pyramid
now we've got a nosebleed
we're terrified of heights and we're
looking at personal knowledge management
and I know that some of the co-hosts
will be very excited for this because
this is part of your building a second
brain course that's right so this is my
my current area of focus essentially
after the the two previous courses I
noticed that you know people would have
incredible testimonials from GTD I have
my whole to-do list my tasks completely
organized my habits are great that's all
wonderful but it always came back to
knowledge right like I seem to know
things to have subject matter expertise
to have work experience to have
professional you know wisdom speaking of
wisdom and I'm not sure where that goes
it doesn't seem to go into all these
productivity apps at the very bottom
there's no place for it there doesn't
seem to go in
the five stages of GTV which is all
about action there's no place for it in
habit formation it's just kind of there
and I started noticing in my own work so
usually what happened this month I'm at
the frontier of knowledge and then my
audience is just behind me right so it's
like I'm encountering the the while but
whatever is next yeah and then I can I
can hear them in the back just a few
steps behind in many cases just like
clamoring for the solution yeah and
that's what's kind of propels me forward
but I I read the actually the updated
edition of GTD which which was in 2015
it came out and he says all these times
you know there's there actionable
information tasks and then there's
reference information which is
everything else right and he keeps
saying it I think seven or eight times
he says you know reference information
is one of the most powerful high
potential ways of completely you know
revolutionizing your productivity but
then he just doesn't say anything it's
like essentially I think that's amazing
yeah it's it's outside the the purview
of GTD and I just thought oh my gosh
like this is the next frontier this is
what's next
Yeah right like GTD it's in my opinion
solved tasks it's gonna be around a
hundred years from now but there's this
whole other thing which is everything
else right and I just started you know
trying things from my own this is how it
usually happens I experiment from my own
I start reading books I do interviews I
do consulting projects and then through
all this activity which I have to do to
pay the bills fortunately something
emerges which is this thing that I now
call building a second brain which is
the kind of the brand that's my
particular take on a field which is
actually I discovered a pre-existing
academic discipline called personal
knowledge management okay I didn't know
that interest yeah it's it's it's young
it started in the 90s I've interviewed
the guy who who sort of coined the term
actually in a paper but it's a thing you
know it's related to what's called
personal information management but I
think different and then it's focused
more on like that your tacit knowledge
your personal experience your subject
matter expertise and and they're
starting to be conferences on it there's
you know a key then
journals specifically dedicated to it
and now I as far as I know I'm one of
the first sort of brands or products
that is is there to teach people how to
do it for themselves I understand so I'm
looking at progressive summarization PA
RA
and workflow strategies can we run
through those yes yes
so my methodology that's emerged over
the years has three sort of legs to the
stool and they correspond to the three I
have stages of my own just like GTD
which is the stages are remember connect
and create okay so that's essentially
the three things that you do with
knowledge what do you do acknowledge you
first of all have to remember it you
have to know what's there be able to
recall it that's the first stage the
second is you have to connect it you
know you want to do more than just stock
pile you know bricks of knowledge in a
warehouse you want to actually mix and
match it you want to see oh this is like
this this is different from that this
sheds light on this other thing it's
like that's what that's what creativity
is is making connections between things
and I have a second so progressive
summarization is my the method I've
developed for the first stage which is
remember para is the organizational
system I've developed for the second
stage which is connect and workflow
strategies is the third one for the
third stage which is creates and
basically what this has to do with is my
my belief which is that you only know
what you make and that's actually a
quote in in Latin it's vedam episome
factum from this eighteenth-century yeah
I think Italian philosopher and it's
actually very succinctly describes a
philosophy of knowledge which is that
you know until you actually know it
through experience right embodied
experience you've actually taken action
on it you've made something out of it
you have tested it in some way it's not
actually your knowledge it's just
information right if I read a book on
you know horticulture and I have ten
thousand words of notes on horticulture
that's not knowledge for me it's
knowledge for them but to me that
just information but if I go out and you
know plant an orchard and try all these
things make mistakes
trial and error then I can slowly
convert that information into my own
personal knowledge you've transcended
the ability to remember as well the
listeners who are familiar with the
Fineman technique
I guess leverage is something which is
quite similar to this which is that it's
your job not only to read something
remember it
latch it onto the existing pieces of
information that you have in associated
and non associated fields but also
finally to then be able to re explain it
to someone who has no understanding of
whatever the field is that you're
talking about and that's like the icing
on the top of the cake that the the
final Keystone in the bridge so to speak
that locks everything together right
like if you can do that the role of the
other stage is really kind of it just
allowing you to do that yes that's
exactly my belief is this this entire
pyramid the whole reason it's worth
doing is to create new things right it's
it's to actually produce something of
novel value in the world that would not
be there if it was not for you without
that this is all just like really like
kind like navel-gazing it's just like
what's the word it's just like widget
making print it's not even what you're
making it's just like an anything yeah
exactly yeah you're not making anything
it looks widgets' are useful yeah it's
all the places um it's a touch on it at
the very beginning youssef that all of
the listeners will know one of the
co-hosts he describes himself as a
furious indexer of information like his
his Evernote I want to say is like up to
between five and ten thousand notes on
there now and it's the meta tags are
unbeli imeem it would be like it's like
heaven for you to yoga you would you'd
love it all very very beautifully
designed but his point is that it is
just ruthless indexing and when you
don't actually then bring that forward
into something and as a perfect example
for me and some of the listeners might
think as well like
oh well I enjoy reading I enjoy personal
development IFI and maybe I enjoy
everything like you know whatever form
of media it is but I currently don't
have an outlet that gives me a creative
medium in which to put this on display
and that was one of the main reasons for
me why I started this podcast that I
didn't have a platform in which I could
talk about things that was interested in
and then begin to layer on top of each
other all of the different things that I
was learning about as I went on and that
I'd speak to you or James clear or rory
sutherland or you know whoever it might
be
and exactly oh I've now augmented my
existing understanding with that and not
only have I had my understanding and
their understanding but when we've
discussed them and brought them together
the sum has been greater than the whole
of the parts and I now had leveled up
and I know all of this extra stuff I
didn't even know existed before exactly
exactly
yeah that's that's absolutely key and it
goes back to that thing of being artists
we're just we're not trained or educated
in any way to think of ourselves as
creators and that's the term I like to
use creator you know because you can be
creating anything it's wet it's websites
it's videos it's interviews it's events
right but until you actually step out
and you really we're you're putting
yourself on the line right like people
who are endlessly just accumulating
knowledge and queuing up
I mean that is that is it's such a it's
such a non participatory way of living
in my view you know better to read want
to consume one-tenth as much as much
information online and actually put that
to use rather than just like racking up
the you know the vanity metrics I think
that's that's what it is
I agree I'm just briefly before we move
on to the pinnacle at level 5 I wondered
if you could just give us a brief
explanation of your progressive
summarization strategy I know for many
people that and me included it's
selfishly for myself I like to read on a
kindle paperwhite because it's
low distraction my phone is fetid with
work stuff that I can't really get away
from so for me exporting notes and I
don't want to interrupt my read flow to
create notes and for listeners at home
they may also have the problem of I read
something I can maybe do a little review
in my head at the end of each chapter
but four or five or six chapters deep I
can't remember what was in Chapter one
and then what is your your process for
you're reading a book or you're reading
a very long article a big chunk of
information how are you how are you
noting that down yeah great question
the thing is though Chris I have a
column three minutes [ __ ]
right we're going to go at the top of
the pyramid just in time project project
management what's happening up there
so really coming back to that idea that
projects are like the best unit of
measurement for modern work just-in-time
project management is basically a nubuck
just a new way of thinking about
projects where instead of planning for
in advance and having very detailed
timelines and Gantt charts and all these
things just as the name implies you do
it just in time you do it at the last
minute why and I know it's so so for the
very same reason that just-in-time
manufacturing which is where I borrowed
that from completely revolutionize
manufacturing which is that when you so
if you think about it everything else
being equal the best time to do
something is at the last minute right
when you do something right before it's
actually needed you have as much
information as possible right you have
as much wisdom as you can gather these
the solution you're creating is actually
close in time to the problem that it's
trying to solve so you're not going to
be creating something and then weeks or
months pass and it's no longer valid
coordination is easier you can bring
bring together everyone that needs to be
there for that solution just when it's
actually needed instead of like oh can
you send me that thing that's happening
in three months the only reason that we
can't that that sounds totally
irresponsible and it sounds impossible
is we've lived in a world full of
friction right you had to mail things
around you had to schedule meetings you
had to go find knowledge and alive
somewhere but what I found and this is
emerged almost to my surprise is that
when you have your knowledge
externalized in a central tool like in
building a second brain you can instead
of starting from scratch with each new
project though let me go research this
thing let me go read a book you have all
these little packets these atoms of
knowledge already at your disposal and
what a project becomes really is just
looking at what's available snapping
together these modules like LEGO pieces
right and doing it just in time so you
have as much information as possible
about the problem you're solving and
then just snapping it together and
there's your so there's your project and
it this is this result this results in
these uh I have I have a twenty-one part
series on this on my blog where I really
get into some insanely minuttes things
that I'm sure your audience well some of
your audience will love but um it's
behind my pay wall so I so if some of my
blog articles cost $10 a month to read I
want to give that that disclaimer but if
someone's interested in that that's you
know twenty one twenty two thousand
words
just on just-in-time project management
Wow Tiago I I don't want to take up any
more of your time today has been exactly
what I wanted it to be it's been
fantastic before you leave can you tell
the listeners where they can find you
online where they can head to get more
of this information if they want it yes
really my website is the portal to
everything else it's forte labs fo RT e
la b SC o--
not comm co and that has links to my
blog my courses my social media my email
newsletter really everything fantastic
Thiago it's been an absolute blast I
hope you've revolutionised a lot of
people's workflows and speaking of
just-in-time you have about 30 seconds
before your next call so if thank you so
much for your time perfect Chris thank
you so much been a real pleasure it's
really happy to talk about this and
let's do a part taste of that
[Music]